if you want to raise venture capital for
your business make sure you already have
the groundwork laid out and you have
momentum and some customers for your
business otherwise you're going to be
dead in the water they're gonna say no
or they're gonna kill you on your
valuation hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe the Hunger entrepreneurs
deserve health and today I made some
questions from one of my YouTube viewers
Pablo Pablo's awesome is commenting on
tons of videos and he's been very active
so Thank You Pablo and I'm excited to be
able to try to give back and help him as
well
so he wrote insane he's got a business
he's in the developing stages he's got
some seed funding he's already built it
up a little bit he's had consistent
organic growth after getting the funding
from friends and family now wants to
expand and is looking for venture
capital help him so Pablo I used to be
in the VC business I looked at all the
business plans that came in and 99
percent of them plus got rejected the
main reason is you have to make sure
that you have some momentum with your
company so it sounds like you're beyond
the startup stage that's great I want to
see first that you have some customers
show me that people will pay you what
for what you do make sure people will
spend their dollars on you it doesn't
have to be a lot of money but they're
spending money with you the venture
capital you want to go after is
expansion I'm not paying you to invest
in your product I don't want to see R&D
costs I don't want to see huge salaries
for yourself I want to see expansion
what you've done works and needs to be
fixed you know there's some improvements
but it works and you are now ready to
blow this thing up when you're going
after venture capital it can be a
full-time job you want to look at funds
that are related to what you're doing
they have had portfolio companies who
have invested in similar types of
companies those are the guys who you
want to target because they want to see
that you can have a serious opportunity
but also you might be able to help some
of their portfolio companies do well as
well when you're talking to the venture
capitalists you want to show you have a
management team in place
people who've done this before if you
don't have the expertise in-house bring
on a board of advisor bring on people
who have some experience even if they're
just an advisor you
can leverage their name to help you you
want to show that there's momentum and
traction with your business that people
are paying you for what you're doing and
you want to show that there's a serious
opportunity for whatever your market is
if you go in too soon if you don't have
that stuff ready yet you're gonna waste
your time
because they're gonna say no or if
they're slightly interested you're gonna
get killed on your valuation
you're gonna lose too much of your
business that it's not worth it so if
you're ready if you're at that point
start reaching out and know that it's an
opportunity cost because you're not
going to spend time growing your
business anymore you're gonna be out
raising dollars but if you're not there
yet
focus on it get there get people paying
you know some momentum because I don't
want to see you waste your time and for
those of you watching I don't want to
see you waste your time either you have
to get to that point try to get to
survival try to get to the point where
you don't necessarily need the venture
capital it's great to help you grow but
you could continue on doing what you're
doing as well then you're negotiating
from a position of strength most of the
people who came to me looking for
funding had nothing
they had err they had a plan on paper
these seeds will not fund that you have
to have momentum attraction and it
sounds like poeple is already on the
right track but you've gotta make sure
you're making some revenue that's the
way to start looking interesting to a
venture capitalist in terms of reaching
out do your research find the VCS who
have targeted portfolios who have money
to spend and just email them it's not
hard to get in front of a VC it's not
hard for them for you to get their email
address and to send them your one pager
your executive summary it's hard to get
them to say yes so that's why you want
to focus on those criteria
good luck Pablo thank you again for all
the stuff you've done on YouTube all the
comments other likes I really appreciate
it
for those of you watching if you like
this video just like Pablo please give
it a thumbs up below and I want to know
what you have to think I love seeing
your comments come in let me know what
you think about this video or if you
have a question for your own business
I'd love to try to answer it for you
please leave in the comment section
below thank you guys I'll see you soon
you